Transcriptor: Angelica Perrusquia
Revisor: Silvina Katz
¿Cómo están, bien?
Fíjense que en todos estos años
que he trabajado como rector
me ha pasado algo muy característico
y es que me siento con
los diferentes rectores
de las universidades públicas y privadas
y siempre nos quejamos de lo mismo
es que los chavos llegan
mal preparados a la universidad,
no saben leer,
no saben escribir,
tienen mil errores de ortografía,
no tienen habilidades sociales,
no son emprendedores,
una cantidad de cosas.
Entonces dije, el problema tiene que estar
en la educación media superior,
en las preparatorias.
Y entonces me fui con
los directores de preparatorias
y les dije: "Oye ¿qué pasa?
¿Están formando mal a los jóvenes?"
Y me dicen: "Hombre, el problema
no somos nosotros, son las secundarias;
ahi algo esta funcionando mal".
Y entonces me fui a las secundarias
Y me dijeron: "no aquí no es
el problema, es en primaria".
Y me fui a primaria y me dijeron:
"no, el problema es en el kínder".
y en los kínder, ¿qué les tocó decir?,
que los papás no se comprometen.
Al final, nadie tiene la razón de porqué
estamos funcionando mal.
Y entonces me dí a la tarea de viajar
por diferentes partes del mundo
a conocer lo que hacen bien y mal
los sistemas educativos.
Y encontré algo bien interesante,
que la mayoría de los sistemas
educativos en América Latina
están centrados en la memorización.
Y entonces a un niño lo atacan y le dicen:
"Dime la fecha de nacimiento
de esta persona,
dime cuánto mide el río más largo,
dime la altura de tal volcán".
Y entonces nos olvidamos
de hacerlos entender
que lo verdaderamente
importante del conocimiento
es construir nuevo conocimiento
De qué sirve que un niño se sepa
cuales son todas las capitales del mundo,
si no sabe qué es una forma de gobierno
y como va a afectar a un país.
De qué le sirve saber
cual es la montaña más alta,
si no entiende que hoy, en el planeta
mil cien millones de personas
no comieron absolutamente nada.
Y entonces, hace unos años
me peleé con una maestra.
Una maestra de éstas duras
que me decía que la letra con sangre entra
y yo le decía, mire maestra,
a mí me importan tres cacahuates
la fecha de nacimiento de Benito Juárez.
Se molestó mucho y me dijo:¡ Sacrilegio!
¡como se le ocurre decir eso, rector!
¡ El benemérito de las Américas!
Yo le dije, mire la fecha de nacimiento
de Benito Juárez o de cualquier prócer
es una casualidad, no importa
que sea el 21 de marzo en Oaxaca
lo importante es cuales fueron
los 5 valores más importantes
del gobierno de Benito Juárez y cómo se
podrían aplicar hoy en México en el 2019
o en cualquier país de América Latina.
Por qué el "respeto
al derecho ajeno es la paz"
cuando hoy tenemos más de 300 mil muertos
solo en México y súmenle
los de América Latina.
Entonces ahí se torna más importante
el pensamiento crítico de un niño.
Y entonces a uno le dicen:
"¿Oye, te sabes la tabla del 7?"
"¡Por supuesto! Me la
enseñaron de memoria".
"7 X 1= 7, 7 X 2 = 14"
"¿Te sabes la tabla del 250?"
"¡Ay no, es súper díficil!"
¡Claro que no!
250 X 2 = 500, 250 X 3 = 750
es muy fácil cuando empiezas a analizar
que simplemente sumando,
logras un objetivo.
Entonces, ¿qué quiero decir con esto?.
Que el sistema educativo
se está equivocando
cuando se centra en simplemente pensar
que los cerebros de los niños
son recipientes donde tenemos que meter
una gran cantidad de información
que simplemente esta ahí, ¿para qué?
aprobar un examen.
Necesitamos que ése conocimiento
se convierta en ¿qué?
en nuevo conocimiento.
Entonces, esta es
la hipótesis del siglo XXI,
el conocimiento es
el nuevo petróleo del mundo.
El petróleo se va a acabar.
Se va a acabar no solo porque
se va a acabar físicamente
porque es un recurso no renovable.
Se va a acabar porque el mundo
ya no quiere usar petróleo.
Y entonces los países han entendido
que el conocimiento
es lo que va a sostener las economías.
Esto lo han desarrollado la mayoría
de los países importantes
y ¿ qué hacen para eso?
Tienen un buen sistema educativo.
No hay un solo país, que tenga un mal
sistema educativo, que tenga riqueza.
Estamos condenados a la pobreza
si no tenemos un buen sistema educativo.
Y entonces fíjense,
estos son datos de la OMPI
de la Organización Mundial
de la Propiedad Intelectual del 2017.
EE. UU. registró más de 150 mil patentes,
ahí ven Uds., China,
que en los 70 tenía muchísimos problemas,
pasó de 300 mil patentes registradas
nuevo conocimiento.
Corea del Sur, que hace 30 años tenía
una economía menor que la de nosotros
hoy tiene casi 91 mil
patentes registradas.
Y como está América Latina,
México 407 patentes,
Colombia 166 y Brasil 714.
En una economía del conocimiento,
nos estamos dando un tiro en la cabeza.
Y esto hablando de innovación, también
un estudio que se hizo en 70 países
donde se analizó quienes son
los países más innovadores.
Miren el primero y miren de los 70 países
en que lugares estamos
los de América Latina.
La realidad es que nuestro
sistema educativo
no esta funcionando como lo necesitamos.
Y mientras no funcione,
vamos a estar condenados a la pobreza.
¿Qué hay que hacer, no?
Vamos a hacer,
vamos a buscar una solución,
porque claro, hay gente que dice:
"Oiga, es que sí se tiene que
memorizar para aprender".
Claro que hay que memorizar, por supuesto.
Pero no simplemente
memorizar para dejarlo ahí,
es memorizar para construir
nuevo conocimiento.
Esta es la primera cosa
que hay que hacer,
esta es una definición de educación,
que a mí me costó 20 años
y que todavía está en construcción.
Hay que formar jóvenes creativos.
La creatividad no es un tema
de pintores o artistas,
es una manera de vivir.
Que genere innovación aplicada a problemas
cotidianos o a nuevo conocimiento,
pero ¿saben qué?
Generando riqueza,
desarrollo para un país.
Yo le digo mucho a mis alumnos,
cada que me siento con ellos les digo,
miren, cuando Uds. salen a la calle
y se encuentran un bache,
tienen 2 caminos,
el primero es criticar a las autoridades,
"oiga es que se roban el dinero,
porque no tapan los baches",
pero la segunda es,
"porque no me uno con un chavo
de la universidad tecnológica
y con uno de la universidad autónoma
y vamos a crear un pavimento en base
a material reciclado que sea a menor costo
y sea más fácil aplicarlo".
Siempre los problemas son
una solución para algo.
Pero tenemos que llevar al
sistema educativo
para que la innovación sea el objetivo,
no importa maestra si te sientes
muy conductista o constructivista,
cualquier tipo de modelo que quieras usar,
o si las competencias es lo que tú buscas,
genera innovación.
Y la innovación tiene que
salir de la emoción.
Un niño que no está emocionado
frente al aprendizaje,
primero, no va feliz a la escuela,
y segundo no va a poder generar
ningún nuevo conocimiento.
La segunda cosa es bien interesante,
miren, este concepto lo he denominado:
los 4 analfabetismos.
La primera revolución industrial
a finales del siglo XVIII,
fue la que la marcó
las máquinas a vapor, ¿no?
y entonces el tren a vapor y los barcos
y todo esto y fue muy importante que
la gente supiera leer y escribir, ¿no?
Entonces era importante que tú empezaras
a salir de esa ignorancia en que estaban.
Pero después viene
una segunda revolución industrial,
y es la revolución lo que se
hacía en serie, ¿no?
coches en serie y vienen
todas las fábricas
y habían dos países que
empezaron a liderear todo esto
que eran Estados Unidos e Inglaterra,
y también varios países de Europa.
Entonces, al liderear
Estados Unidos e Inglaterra
el inglés se volvió la necesidad mundial,
se volvió el idioma de los negocios.
Entonces quien no sabía inglés,
pues había un problema,
porque era el idioma de los negocios,
incluso en la actualidad.
Pero después viene la 3a.
revolución industrial,
la de las computadoras,
¿no?, la del internet
casi al final del siglo XX, y entonces,
quien no sabía manejar una computadora
también era una o es
un analfabeta, pero ojo,
estamos en la 4ta. revolución industrial,
la revolución de
la inteligencia artificial,
las redes neuronales.
Entonces, hoy se vuelve prioritario que
nuestros niños en el sistema educativo,
entiendan conceptos de
inteligencia artificial,
sepan conocer lenguajes de programación,
entiendan que es una red neuronal.
Pero si Uds. analizan
estos cuatro analfabetismos,
en México, apenas estamos
en la primera parte.
Estamos resolviendo el que la gente,
por fin pueda leer y escribir,
del 100 % de la gente.
¿Inglés? menos del 5 %
de los mexicanos hablamos inglés.
¿Computadoras? Vámonos al sur de México
y seguramente no saben mucha gente
usar una computadora
y ni se diga inteligencia artificial.
Tenemos un grave problema,
mientras el mundo va muy rápido,
nosotros estamos estáticos, porque nuestro
sistema educativo no está generando
las soluciones que se necesitan.
Pero ahí va la tercera, tenemos 10 cosas
que enseñar además de todo el currículum
que puede venir en un plan de estudios.
La gente necesita tomar decisiones,
saber tomar decisiones ¿ pero saben qué?
resolviendo problemas, eso es fundamental.
Nos cuesta mucho a los latinoamericanos
tomar decisiones, nos lo critican mucho.
La segunda, tenemos que desarrollar
inteligencia emocional.
Saben que cuando yo estudié,
a mi me decían
los niños no lloran, los hombres
no lloran, ¿por qué?
Claro que lloramos y nos gusta llorar.
Y es importante llorar y es importante
entender las emociones
y los sentimientos de los demás.
Tercero, la creatividad como modo de vida.
Cuarto, que se adapten fácilmente.
Hoy una persona vive en Aguascalientes,
mañana en Londres y regresa a Bolivia
y después se va a Argentina, así es.
Tienen que entender su mexicanidad,
su cultura, pero saberse adaptar
al mundo donde les toque vivir.
Quinto, asumir riesgos,
que no les dé miedo
enfrentarse a las cosas.
Seis, trabajar en equipo.
Es imposible hoy, construir algo,
si no es de manera interrelacionada.
Seis, ser resilientes.
¿Saben qué nos dicen
los emprendedores hoy?
Fracasa rápido, límpiate las rodillas,
las lágrimas y al otro día
enfrenta el mundo.
La resiliencia hoy es fundamental para
cualquier niño en el sistema educativo
pero también tener un pensamiento crítico
no sólo me aprendo la fecha de nacimiento
de Benito Juárez, sé que fue lo importante
que pasó con él o de cualquier prócer,
cualquier historia importante
del mundo, ¿no?
Nueve, ser sensibles.
Algún día, escribí una frase
que me encanta mucho,
que dice: "Una sociedad
que pierde la capacidad
de sentir el dolor del otro,
está perdida".
Si a mi estudiante o a mi hijo
le importa un bledo
los inmigrantes centroamericanos
de los semáforos,
señores, estamos perdidos.
Vivimos en una sociedad que estamos
como en una cápsula,
donde no nos importa lo que pasa
alrededor, y la realidad es que tenemos
que poner los pies en la tierra,
enseñarles a nuestros niños
la realidad del mundo
para que la puedan mejorar.
Y saben que, la décima, tenemos que
ser perseverantes, tenemos que trabajar
una y otra vez, y lo ensayo y me cuesta.
Y la 4ta. cosa que tenemos que hacer
es ser emprendedores, pero no solo
emprendedores tradicionales.
Esta es una tesis que desarrollé
en una maestría y es:
en América Latina el sistema
educativo esta centrado
a formar empleados, es una realidad,
a muchos de nosotros nos educaron
para que al terminar nuestra carrera,
hiciéramos unos currículums
y buscáramos amigos en el gobierno
o en alguna empresa
para que nos dieran chamba, ¿ no?
Así nos educaron, pero ojo,
hay otros países que estan
formando emprendedores
pero hay un grupo de países
que estan formando
emprendedores de pensamiento exponencial.
¿Qué quiere decir eso?
La gente que ha entendido que con el uso
de la tecnología de la inteligencia
artificial, de las redes neuronales
pueden llegar a
7,500 millones de personas.
¿Cúal es mi reto? en lo que
hago cada día en la educación,
dar ese salto cuántico de formar
empleados, a formar pensadores,
emprendedores de pensamiento exponencial,
¿para qué? Para que creen
este tipo de empresas.
Estas empresas que tienen
un alto crecimiento,
empresas que han entendido que con
la tecnología fácilmente pueden llegar
a 7,500 millones de personas.
Entonces, cuatro cosas:
formar niños en innovación.
Segundo: enseñarles que entiendan redes
neuronales, pensamiento exponencial.
Tercero, las 10 llaves, y cuarto,
formar emprendedores exponenciales.
¿Para qué?
Este mundo en el que vivimos es un mundo
hermoso, tiene cosas maravillosas.
Pero lastimosamente nuestras generaciones
han hecho mucho daño.
Hoy tenemos unas desigualdades
terribles entre ricos y pobres,
unas desigualdades que
nos van a llevar al colapso.
Pues hoy, tenemos que formar
niños y jóvenes diferentes
para que puedan construir el mundo
donde todos queremos vivir.
Muchas gracias.